[Music]
i've known him since i was about like 17
so i've known him for a really long time
he did the work obviously you know i
just think he did an incredible job
being true to the character
collaborating together
i knew we're tied together to a certain
degree forever
tied together forever three days after
losing his friend
michael b jordan honored chadwick
writing one of the last times we spoke
you said we were forever linked
and now the truth of that means more to
me than ever
we got to see first hand the strong bond
chadwick and michael shared
from intense acting scenes to just
joking around
was there a little bit of a competition
of who i mean
who was going to be more fine
[Laughter]
i was less concerned about like you know
whether my bicep was as big as his bicep
or my shoulder
you know that's that's that's your plan
man i play sports he plays boyz i mean
we're pretty both athletic okay i'm
saying
just i'll just say whatever whatever
michael says you showed me how to be
better honor purpose and create legacy
one of the ways chadwick did that was by
giving back in 2018
right in the middle of his cancer battle
the star visited young patients and
their families
at the saint jude children's research
hospital
thank you made me you so awesome i leave
making me happy
now one of the big questions is what
happens with black panther ii
director ryan coogler has been working
on a script and many fans are adamant
the role of king t'challa should not be
recast
i know that you can't have a black
panther now without a two on it
so we love you and we celebrate it
chadwick grew up in anderson south
carolina and the mayor is reportedly
planning a celebration of the star's
life on thursday
followed by a screening of black panther
denzel washington who secretly paid for
chadwick's acting classes
tells e.t quote he was a gentle soul and
a brilliant artist who will stay with us
for eternity through his iconic
performances
i am king of wakanda just get him out
i understand
denzel's son tenets star john david
washington shared this memory of when
the two first met at a vanity fair photo
shoot
welcome to vanity fair we're not models
we're used to being in front of a moving
camera
so i think it makes you more comfortable
he was just as warm and as
humble as one could be you know embraced
me like a brother even though it was
like a five-minute
embrace i just have a tremendous a
tremendous amount of respect for him and
what he stood for
and how he lived his life